[Musica]
sapete che in poche parole 2 uscito sei
anni fa alla fine tutto il resto è anche
questo buttare vecchissimi format che la
gente per anni mi ha chiesto di rifare e
metterli in mezzo a questo calderone ed
esattamente come i primi due episodi ho
chiesto a voi di riassumere film e
telefilm
in pochissime parole ma questa volta con
una piccola gabola non mettermi il
titolo di quello che state riassumendo
perché io lo so che ci sono dei geni tra
di voi e non mi avete deluso come al
solito si parte con molta calma baby
yoda poi diciamo che potete fare di
meglio
squinzi e ora io adoro quando
riassumendo con una singola parola però
squinzia che un epiteto stupido per
descrivere una ragazza un pochino
disinibita può andar bene per qualsiasi
cosa ma mi hanno dovuto suggerire che è
una parola che ripete spesso bar ma in
aula met your mother in italiano quindi
davide puoi anche le parti dai [ __ ]
fuori da casa miliano l'ho mai capito ma
ad halloween diverso da coniglio perché
figo ufficio studi o in volta che ho
fatto un in poche parole c'era sempre
donnie darko e ho capito che questo film
non l'avete digerito ma [ __ ] tua e
mammina quello presa devo dire sul
personale perché quando fai una domanda
su instagram c'è sempre il simpaticone
intorno che ti scrive su capaccio messo
un secondino di più per capire che
troisi in ricomincio da tre a un
condannato a morte tocca il parco di
secondi bill è un riassunto subito si è
falso
la famiglia ittero ora non so che non ci
siete arrivati tutti i simpson ma non
puoi essere un vincitore se ct luigi è
una
carabinieri ritorno al futuro ma senza
le americanate e ovviamente a spasso nel
tempo con boldi de sica bravo una chicca
che pochi si ricordano compie un viaggio
interstellare di 76 anni ma la meta era
affianco alla sua camera da letto
a volte siete veramente stronzi quanti
piani sequenza vuoi
sì questo ha molteplici risposto e per
esempio berben per esempio 1917 o per
esempio l'inizio di amici come prima
eh no non sto scherzando il suo urlo
terrorizza un intero paese cose strane
non male si parla di breaking mezzo in
cima abbiamo quello più subdolo wwe
sotto abbiamo quella intelligente e
simpatica i professori di chimica
dovrebbero essere pagati di più
e voi droga pelato e un mariuolo bravo a
tirare i pugni combatte contro il
campione e perde però è felice idea io
buttare i simpatici venditori di carta
seguiti ovunque dalle telecamera che la
di e muta
ci ho messo un sacco per riuscire a
capire questa di svolta ma è django un
fan di adolf weber numero a falato e gli
dà da mangiare il marciapiede porca
[ __ ]
siamo due uomini e mezzo trovare questa
coppia di riassunti dello stesso film lo
mette in prospettiva c'è chi si
focalizza su una cosa e cioè che si
focalizza su un'altra affonda una ricca
vecchia racconta di quando era giovane
in crociera e si tombata un poveraccio
ha curato io quanto siete stronzi orfano
complessato scopre di essere io sono tuo
padre e ha ragione lui era mio padre io
e il cane non vale non va non vai alla
news
e adoro che tu abbia messo le moti
congiusta the rock flexa e salva la
situazione a occhio direi tutta la
filmografia di the rock compreso il re
scorpione mia madre si chiama marta è il
riassunto più decontestualizzato ma allo
stesso tempo al centro
per cento azzeccato completamento giusti
che cazzo ragazzi
la signorina fra bioera leggermente
indecisa tra due cose ma le ha messe
entrambe cinque amici al pub se amici al
bar
no questo mollo e l'ultimo riassunto con
cui vi lascio è veramente un piccolo
capolavoro
ci ho messo forse due secondini in più
ad arrivarci ma quando ci arrivi di
svolta la giornata un lungo e tortuoso
viaggio di tre amici per portare un
antico artefatto in salvo
vi amo grazie
[Musica]